probably the most important feature of
outdoor clothing is being water
resistant the next challenge is to make
it a local meditating no substance is
harmful to the environment and so that I
fasted test simple test for flora comedy
material Langsdorf it is tad the droplet
of paraffin oil if it's fully absorbed
let me know for sure that the material
is already having three lines old than
the most of the seasons either doesn't
stock up on fire was fastest seven years
ago antiphon David's took over the reins
of her father's mountain sports
outfitter company and has since been
endeavouring to make the entire
production chain greener
these bicycle pioneers contain no toxic
plastics the vast majority of the new
clothes and backpacks are likewise free
of chemical pollutants he won't give a
tunable emerged we were fully
highlighted to pursuing and ecologically
and socially responsible agenda hulu
versatile it was a question oh nothing
guns why just like a sufficient from to
yet we had this vision of the combining
fair trade with environmentally friendly
productions in pharaonic lubish too much
afternoon of her class design the first
step was convincing the suppliers in
asia to provide toxin-free materials for
production the management had to go
there in person to make the case we
first saw the possibilities years ago
short and then drive to achieve that I
don't want having little critical
editions of the fancy it's not easy
because when yo yo yo you doing Antonia
mind wrong local supply chains or bad
which would in inconvenient at keefe
zoster younkin we're a relatively small
company isn't over hell no I am an
active cleaners want onion fortunately a
new campaign launched by Greenpeace four
years ago was good timing since then
over 70 companies have committed to
making production greener including some
major sports wear manufacturers and
clothing chains God about in pft xenia
duster so quite a lot has happened on
the fluorocarbon seeds must be the
holidays a pure outdoors in part of them
is this a sector that I should not of
mine alternative materials with a
comfortable level of water resistant to
bustle which is my daughter rain we're
meeting the cloud of kuvira's just what
so the functionality has to be okay here
product any [ __ ] that took a while to
know d tables havoc still will decide
let's head on the door what the company
is also won awards for its green
headquarters it invests a lot of money
expertise further development of
cutting-edge materials and they can then
proudly display various quality seals
testifying to their sustainable fair
production conditions the fit was fine
Guinness right spread awareness about
responsible conduct not just in German
landed around the world a lot of errands
on customer conservation Cohen can once
master send out and prepare to spend
more that happened that's where the
still open and information gap when de
comunicarse want some corn around one in
four customers at specialist stores
asked directly about clothes and
backpacks produced in an environmentally
friendly manner and it's those people
who are willing to pay up to 200 euros
for a thin water resistant jacket this
missions every stitch has opened new
climate geography hargadon do a lot of
thinking about my environment since i
think i find a modular you may get more
a cup of coffee okay then i'm a t-shirt
dovish besides at lunch hey good money
for clothes closet in a sustainable
design is really good in sport the
company's next goals are online repair
manuals and a rental system for
backpacks bags and tents fowl day is
committed to the environment and is
eager to persuade customers that
sustainably produced outdoor items are a
sound long-term investment
you